Aaron Sampson here every day we work to
bring you the most relevant gameplay
clips at 2:00 and 7:00 p.m. Pacific so
that you can see how games actually play
with rising storm to Vietnam out I'm
going to take a minute to talk about the
controversial topic of camping and then
show a base defense section so you can
see what I'm talking about Vietnam is a
class-based multiplayer shooter that
feels a lot like early battlefield games
because it's inspired by realism which
can mean different things to different
people the game generally has less
friendly gun handling and favors more
realistic tactics like bounding using
smoke to conceal movement and yes
camping to be honest I've always found
people's extreme dislike of camping to
be a bit confusing because it's just a
tactic but that may be because it fits
well into shooters like rising storm -
Vietnam war isn't supposed to be fair
but games are so developers have a
unique challenge of balancing maps and
in particular asymmetric factions such
as those in this game join us in the
comments below and give your thoughts on
camping where is it appropriate in
multiplayer shooters we're also about to
head to e3 where tons of games are
announced so feel free to share your
thoughts on titles you would like to see
like battlefront 2 as always likes or
subscribes let us know we're getting you
the games you want to see let's get to
it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
enemy is a running Alex
[Applause]
well good
reporting
victory sounds
you